so last week we were in Chicago We're
showering getting ready for a show he
comes out of the shower and he's getting
ready to get changed and I go in there
and I see a pair of underwear in the
trash can there's only one thing I know
about that
underwear it's definitely not mine why
is there underwear in the trash
can I got to know so I I I'm like hey uh
yeah why is there underwear in the trash
can what why is there underwear in the
trash can and he just laughs first of
all I had a
blowout you had a what oh I had a
blowout a
what I had a I had a blowout and he came
around the corner looking like ET
wrapped in towels after his shower just
I mean he definitely got me when I was
vulnerable do that right now